[Musique]
je suis né en allemagne il ya une
quarantaine d'années
même un tout petit peu plus de père
autrichien soit dit au passage à l'âge
de 18 ans après avoir terminé mes études
secondaires je suis venu en france où je
suis vraiment spontanément tombé
amoureux de paris je me souviens
l'époque avoir écrit à ma petite amie
qui était resté en allemagne que
j'aurais dû naître en france et que
j'avais l'intention de corriger le sort
ce que j'ai fait
[Musique]
et j'ai trouvé un atelier dans un
quartier de paris parce que j'avais
ouvert le françois rat lavage numéro 27
1 samedi matin j'ai trouvé un atelier
qui me convenait je me rendais pas du
tout content que cet atelier était tout
d'abord dans un quartier de passionnant
qui était le faubourg saint-antoine je
ne savais pas ce que c'était
je me rendais pas du tout content ce
jour là que j'allais lier une partie
importante de ma vie
une partie importante de ma vie active
en tous les cas un ce quartier qu'est le
faubourg saint-antoine auxquelles je
suis attaché maintenant je dirais
vraiment partout les fibres de mon corps
[Musique]
le tout
ça me ramène à mon enfance ou pour aller
à l'école je devais traverser une
scierie et si mes souvenirs aujourd'hui
sont exacerbées l'odeur dans cette série
qui me passionnait et je la sens pire
est toute ma vie or cette odeur je la
retrouve aujourd'hui dans ma vie de tous
les jours dans mon atelier et j'ai pensé
que peut-être dans ma vie j'ai suivi
tout simplement l'odeur du bois
[Musique]
non
on ne
d'une part il ya le vieux faubourg qui
existent encore qui subsistent encore et
puis alors il ya toutes les
transformations je dirais presque les
destructions qui se font dans le
faubourg qui me rendent extrêmement
triste parce que ce que l'on fait
actuellement dans le faubourg et
l'annoncé de la disparition d'un
faubourg auxquelles je suis attaché
c'est à dire lorsque on démolit comme
c'est le cas ici en face il ya le
couvent du bon secours que l'on vient de
détruire partiellement pour construire
un immeuble salubre et propre qui
n'était évidemment pas destinée aux
habitantes on a délogé les petites gens
du faubourg
ça c'est un immeuble pour cadres moyens
et cadres supérieurs
lorsqu on fait ça on déloge les artisans
parce que les artisans ne peuvent vous
font exister que dans les vieux murs
pour différentes raisons qui sont que
dans mes vieux murs les loyers sont
encore à peu près abordable et que toute
l'ambiance qui est attaché à cette
vieille pierre disparaît lorsqu'on monte
des horreurs en béton
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors faut se contenter un petit pont
[Musique]
von la résignation rentrer dans la vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
enfin le trou c'est quand on fait son
compte une fois qu'on est vieux si on a
passé une bonne vie tranquille quoi
c'est ça l'essentiel après tout si on a
trouvé le bon aure désarroi trouvèrent
encore non poignon d'autres avec une
panne pourquoi ces trois qualités la
dépendance et la liberté personne qui
vous empêche on n avait pas de battre
contre un brillant qu'on aime voir il
enlevait son sable il disait bonjour
monsieur aulas il parlait poliment
hélas si ça me convenait j'accepte de le
faire si seb convenait pas de 10 des
nombreux cieux je regrette mais je ne
vous ferai pas votre main ou bleu peut
parfaitement on travaillait qui vous
plaisait
tassé font ménage pas pour arranger
des gens des commerçants quoi qui charge
des affaires d'état ferdinand crois pas
mais c'est un beau jackpot et
poursuivons des pommes rouges
il avait dû aller se promener gérante la
porte
alors ça c'est quelqu'un d'autre mot ce
que tu viens avec plein de pognon tebib
monsieur combien votre commode
monsieur ma commande n'est pas un vendre
pour vous allez pas pour vous la garde
faune flore et faune ans alors ça c'est
cette grosse campagne on disait j'ai du
koniambo world alors chassé pro croyable
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voyez ce bâtiment
j'ai travaillé là dedans dans l'atelier
qui seront gelés pendant trente ans on
sait c'est un tube et il voir démolir
actuellement
j'étais artisan ébéniste pourquoi gtb
nist parce que mon père était ébéniste
ma mère son père était fabricant de
meubles avant 1870 au 99 rue de charonne
mon grand père me battait fabricant de
meubles grâce à ses 1 dernière en mai
licence iv sentir
j'ai bien tapé alors tous mes oncles
d'un côté comme de l'autre et bénisse
j'ai même eu un ancêtre qui a travaillé
pour l'eau or les groupes avec des ris
dit est pareil et fallait que je sois
béni sea dont on était un scandale à
[Musique]
ra jour supporte les sourires et les
solives remarqué des ailes donc des
mortaise chats sont des solutions 1760
elles ont été utilisées de vieilles
maisons tienne bel alliage ont déjà été
construites sur le tantale
en septembre la chaîne abou 0 11e
[Musique]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes ici cité par chat à des plus
grands et des plus beaux exemples odeurs
d'urbanisme spontanée qui ça tu as créé
dans le faubourg saint-antoine est je
crois un des premiers parce que
voyez-vous ici nous sommes là derrière
c'est la bastille au 2 rue de la
roquette et au bout à travers toutes ces
petites cours qui lia enr débouche en
travers au 21 faubourg saint-antoine
mais alors cette gt composent un tas de
petites cours avec des ateliers partout
partout à tous les étages vous voyez les
vieilles marques marques comme blood aux
bronches et joe de 60 ans à cette
aventure
voyez roger ébéniste au troisième étage
toujours avec des bâtiments disparates
oui sur ie c'est ce qui ponctuent voyous
que c'est excessivement bien ça doit
dater du xviie tchèque 18 jan chèques et
des bâtiments qui se sont construit au
fur et à mesure sans aucun ordre
voyez vous si ce n'est que pour
l'utilisation du travail dans
l'ameublement
[Musique]
voyez encore là bas il y avait encore un
tapissier il ya deux mois sa méhari et
des parts il a pris sa retraite l'an
maintenant elle avait des bureaux toutes
sortes de gens qui ne travaillent pas
dans l'ameublement
[Musique]
voilà ici maintenant nouvelles régions
dans la cour de juin d'abord alors ça
moi et qui nous annonce le beau temps
ils bonheur
[Musique]
garder ces vieux bâtiments regardez ce
un balcon curio là où la rampe avec le
débat du juste même dans des choses très
simples pas il et donne une petite note
audard et en os ouvriers des stores
c'est donc dans des locaux d'habitation
au sud toujours parce que jusqu'en 1914
il y avait toujours le logement à côté
de l'atelier
[Musique]
oh
hamon
[Musique]
et
la paris avant 1914 on comptait douze
mille ouvrier ébéniste ses considérants
ébéniste pur c'est-à-dire alors sans
compter tous les autres métiers annexes
et connexes de l'ameublement qui forment
la grande famille de la fabrication du
baume et à l'ébéniste pure qui fait le
meuble qui travaillent le bois mais il y
a le sculpteur qui s'est spécialisée
futuria marketeurs ce lien vers 10
heures s'il ya des bronzes à femmes
il ya un monteur en bronze avec ma fille
je leur ai hâte d'horreur sur métaux
vous voyez tous ces métiers on a
peut-être 20 qui contribue à faire un
meuble
mais vous monsieur flamand quand avez
vous senti que les choses changent et à
partir de 1919 qui a déjà eu beaucoup de
changements j'étais comment le
commencement de la vente à grande
publicité à l'américaine et alors cette
vente à grande publicité à la meilleure
hygiène a engendré aussi des
fabrications de grande série alors voilà
voilà le grand tourment de l'ameublement
et avant cette fabrication en grande
série a nécessité des machines de plus
en plus perfectionnés et est alors avec
une grande accélération à partir de 1945
46 c'est à dire que les machines se sont
mises à remplacer les hommes exactement
quoi les gens regardent pas dans le
temps quand on arrivait en est un
diamant choisissait pour son métier
c'est les parents qui décident es tu vas
faire sinon tu vas faire ça
peut-être que le hasard m'a favorisé
puisque je les aimais ce que dieu mais
au fait qu'est-ce que c'est un artisan
artisans on a l'impression que c'est une
personne qui a sa liberté expliqué
supérieur je voulais un peu sans être
prétentieux à un ouvrier puisqu'il est
sec de ceux sortis se sentir de quoi
c'est à dire qu'il veut
vivent dans ces zones et avoir soeur
l'éternel facilité de pouvoir faire ce
qu'il dit mais comment vous expliquez
que les artisans inquiétait si nombreux
ce soit si mal défendu devant le
changement a justement ça vient de leur
état d'esprit individuel à l'argile
ce sont des individualistes en général
et avant ils n'étaient pas organisées
n'ont jamais voulu ne se sont jamais
entendus pour être organisé
[Applaudissements]
mon père était tourneur sur bois je suis
de venir tourner l'info voix mais le
centre ne sont pas ses clients tourneur
en définitive c'est une famille de
journée a commencé très jeune à l'époque
on entre dans l'atelier as raison
beaucoup de monde
il fallait beaucoup d'ouvriers parce que
la france à cette époque là faisait de
vie dure les sens louis saez et les
américains plaisante ours est en train
de racheter les modes de photos sont pas
à cette époque le mode du fou pour sa
part toile été renommé dans le monde
entier sait plus où tu avais pas et
maintenant elle s'est beaucoup de
commerçants est beaucoup moins
d'ouvriers y avait quand même temps la
périphérie et ressort lui en a il y
avait au moins 25 tours 9
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
absolument d'apprentissage et nous
souffrions parce qu'il y avait eu une
crise assez assez grave et jusqu'à 30
ans j'ai touché dans la salle à manger
de mes parents dans un litige est pour
moi rire et c'était difficile mais il
faut que je vous explique quand même une
chose si tu es mon père était un très
bon ouvrier
quand le client arrivé à l'atelier de ce
fait renault
vous êtes un artiste c'est parfait mais
alors ce qui nous est cher il diminue de
moitié vrai un peu près sont sans
travail alors je me dis on regarde ma
semaine et encore faut-il alors c'est
pour ça depuis j'ai pris l'habitude de
me dire il faut absolument un salaire
plein salaire c'est pas un pourboire on
ne peut pas payer qu'un programme parce
que j'ai vécu avec un power est sûre
fait qu'aujourd'hui je suis venu à mieux
quand on dit perdant vous êtes un
artiste de l'estomac qui commence
c'est pour vous le virage ça a été comme
la 1930 la sécurité sociale et vous nous
avions à faire avec des artisans
il fallait envisager de faire des os
pour revendre augmenter les prix de
manière virale mettre la sécurité
sociale ce n'est pas le patron du ps
niches fiscales c'était obligatoirement
tendre et très bien qu'il fallait
inclure la sécurité sociale alors quand
je voyais des vieux qui l'avait quittée
rue saint-bernard terral perpétrées non
c'était des mieux aller les voir janvier
pour inclure de santé pris fin sur les
prix de la sécurité sociale ils disent
que tu veux ça me [ __ ] la sécurité
sociale j'en ai jamais profité qui lui
est dédié travail des travailleurs avant
de nous ça a fait faillite
comment veux tu qu'on inclut sage est
possible vous n'êtes pas grande est leur
cas ne mentait pas leurs prix alors
chaque fois qu'on aime voir quand
jacques lurton méprendre la sécurité
sociale ont regardé de travers en disant
terrain les chairs et bien souvent je
revoyais le bihan partie axée quatre
fois sur les bras en disant j'ai faim et
pourtant ils ramènent ces bouts de bois
[Musique]
après il ya une chose qui est certaine
c'est que nous travaillons avec de la
sueur de deux individus
les gens qui travaillaient des machines
du tour automatique autres font du
travail beaucoup plus mal qui est le
mien mais moins sur une machine n'y a
pas de charges sociales soit elle
s'arrête elle mange pas de la machine
comme les individus manger d'autres
parce sinon surtout ce sont les faces
sociaux secret que sur chaque individu
les charges seront basés sur de la sueur
chaude
non
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
vous
ce que je puis vous préciser ces camps
en 24 ans c'est-à-dire cumul 125 ans
depuis 1953
nous avons réalisé 43 pas lu tous
complètement avec la décoration
intérieure dhs et des voûtes en lapis
agile et en or des sols en marbre
enfin tout ce qui est de la grande est
la vraie décoration l'expression des
gènes défense mais je veux lance côté de
modestie régis lefranc
oui
voyez-vous une somme des entreprises de
taille moyenne et je crois pouvoir
préciser que c'est la plus ancienne car
je ne pense pas que qui que ce soit soit
en mesure d'apporter la preuve que je
peux apporter
c'est à dire le passeport de mon arrière
grand père claude mercier que vous voyez
ici représentés et qui datent de 1828
il est venu de sa côte d'or natale
dotées d'un diplôme des mini sera livré
et s'était établit d'abord rue
baudrairie ensuite ici dans la cour du
vampire non plus avant aubry très
rapidement pour des raisons commerciales
facile à comprendre et mon père en 1899
ça c'était la date de ma naissance je
m'excuse de le dire ça ne me rajeunit
pas papa a construit toute cette partie
du bâtiment qui donne vers la rue
théophile roussel et à partir de ce
moment là nous avons continué ce que
nous avions toujours fait ces danses
avons exporté devons continuer à
exporter nous exportions avant la guerre
les avions exportés par exemple le
diamant paix fait le réaliser le palais
real de madrid
pour alphonse reste était charmant
paraît-il nous avons réalisé sarthois y
est c'est l'eau alors nicolas
personnellement j'ai travaillé pour ça
mais c'est le roi fouad l'egypte
travailler pour pouvoir le monténégro
moi même j'ai travaillé pour hiro hito
le japon alors qu'il était prince
impérial
vous voyez le processus est pas qui
c'est continuez à travers tout le golfe
avec ce qu'il représente deux
possibilités de réalisation de qualité
élégante robe représentatif de ce que la
france peut faire comment expliquez-vous
la disparition des artisans du faubourg
il en reste encore certains n'est ce pas
mais il est bien évident que petit à
petit ils se sont découragés quand on
travaille bien c'est toujours un peu
long c'est d'ailleurs ce qui fait que
parfois on nous dit que c'est cher et ça
nous fait mal à l'estomac parce que on
ya mis son petit air définitif n'est
pareil c'est pas de la reconnaissance
qu'on donne enfin c'est tout de même
reconnaissance du travail bien fait moi
je suis là
la génération des voitures à chevaux
j'adorais les chevaux alors v parents
rohmer il ya qui était magnifique avec
des petits chapeaux à plumes et des
petits dit il je sers et là des petites
robes en diable le che poiret est ce que
sa famille et chez soirée c'était
l'élégance moment à mener en victoria
répondit par le cocher ulysse nous avons
gardé très très longtemps jusqu'au
moment où papa résolument moderniste a
bazardé les chevaux et a pris d
autonomie
[Musique]
quels sont vos souvenirs du quartier on
vous savez mon père m'a toujours dit que
le samedi soir c'est malheureux artisans
pratiquer ce que l'on appelait la troll
c'est à dire que ont fabriqué à l'époque
des chambres à coucher en noyer frisé
armoire une porte un petit lit d'une
personne et une petite table de chevet
il mettait tout ça sur leur dos avec un
instrument spéciale il partait vendre
aux mieux offrant parmi les négociants
lille faubourg ça c'est à les souvenirs
assez amusant du faubourg saint-antoine
à 30 c'était un marché en plein vent qui
se tenait sur cette avenue et pour
permettre la vente des meubles pour des
artisans rencontre commande par exemple
oh mon corps de travail c'était un
débouché pour eux qui leur permettait de
survie
maman papa d'apprentissage un bon jour
du fait qu'un client l'avait pas payé
qui comptait sur cette rentrée il dit
louis il faisait des salles à manger
louis 15 me voyais des pelles salle à
manger qui tient en joue essayer ça qui
est bien avec ce maçon champenois on va
aller là troller dans le faubourg - fait
quatre marchands de meubles alors à la
fin le dernier marchand de meubles a
bien voulu acheter la salle à manger
mais à 10% du prix - soeur et moi alors
qu' à ce moment là j'avais envie de me
demander un sou de plus dolor belge
avait bonne mine
voilà alors si à ce moment là vous
seriez venait me dire que ce serait plus
tard artisan ébéniste et bien je leur ai
dit allez vous faire [ __ ]
mais mon père deal sera ébéniste en eau
ou par les dents tordues
si vous n'êtes pas j'en aurais pleuré
mais le professeur lui-même a eu des
larmes aux yeux
le 10 mai monsieur c'est un crime ce que
vous faites là voilà un enfant il
apprend ce qu'il veut sans effort et
vous voulez en faire un ébéniste
alors je suis rentré ou apprenti
ébéniste à 12 ans et 4 mois
la gorge anti préféré savez quand vous
rentrez dans un atelier 8 établi la
poussière des corps ont pas été lavé
depuis des décennies ça fait drôle
d'impression et une cassure dans la vie
[Musique]
où
nous
m
et
[Musique]
alors comme ça vous êtes rentré dans
l'atelier de votre père je suis pas
entrer dans l'atelier de mon père
justement parce que la coutume n'était
pas que le père prenne son fils comme
apprenti il n'a pas l'autorité
nécessaire il le place chez un autre
patron qui lui l'a d'autorité qui lui
n'a pas de sentiments parce que ford
sentiments pour faire un frottis
si vous êtes pris par le sentiment vous
n'avez pas le coeur à le commander le
nécessaire c'est don fehr qui est dieu
sauve en apprentis il faut être dur
c'est à dire un ancien patron et je ne
suis pas plus pour différentes raisons
alors j'en ai changé fille j'ai eu un
autre patron pendant deux ans chat est
très dur et très mal pris mon métier
après vous n'êtes ni rue contes à la
parole à la fin ça va pas si vite
trois ans d'apprentissage en or corps tu
le bâtiment
ensuite on n'est qu'à 80 quand vous
voyez ce qui fait huit ans de travail
pour arriver tout petit ouvrier
[Musique]
j'apportais partout qu'il n'y a pas de
jeunes qui veulent apprendre ce métier
ce métier de sculpteur sur bois parce
que c'est trop difficile
je pense aux médecins pour bien
apprendre et les sculpteurs disent qu'il
faut dix ans ouais alors dix ans il n'y
a pas beaucoup d'études où il faut dix
ans pour remettre ça et moins peiné
peut-être sur son travail
en tout cas physiquement comment vous
expliquez vous que ces obstacles
d'obstacles qui arrête les autres n'est
pas été des obstacles
qu'est ce qui vous plaît tant à ce
travail je sais pas le la liberté
l'indépendance et puis aussi tu part
peut-être le goût de faire un travail
que personne d'autre ne fait de vous
exprimer un travail que vous faites
oui mais on se on est bien obligé aussi
de soutenir parce que c'est pas faire
faire du style c'est pas ça sort pas le
soir c'est pas quelque chose qui
provient de fonds puisque vous faut
traduire les les autres et alors qu'est
ce qu'on fait pour pour ne plus contenir
ce qu'on a en soi qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire
je pense qu'il faut arriver à connaître
tellement bien ce qu'ils ont fait à eux
pour
pour arriver à se mouiller je joue
sûrement que j'arrive pas encore je ne
sais pas comment c'est quel est votre
client principal dans le travail qu'on
fait assez de talent je travaillais au
95 % pour tous les monuments historiques
et en ce moment vous faites quoi pour
l'état c'est moi même travaillons pour
versailles dans le cabinet à l'intérieur
de nos fils il ya des mieux qu'ils sont
tous blancs et qui ne digère pas de
faste et c'était pareil mais refaire
recréer des objets du xviiie siècle en
vivant à la fin du 20e pour une même
personne c'est pas difficile ça c'est la
difficulté ça m'a donné un très beau
leur travail c'est que il faut leur
actuel
il ya un travail une voiture dehors qui
nous amène sur des autoroutes à des
vitesses folles et cetera
ces restaurants la peur de vendre devant
le morceau de bois
essayez de penser et d d'interpréter à
travers l'âme en arriver à redonner il
veut même sensibilité de ce qu'ils ont
fait les anciens mais à l'époque au 18e
français comme on vivait dans les
ateliers et on en dira un groupe s'était
paralysant tout seul qui travaille tout
seul un vérin créant son petit meuble
tout seul ce qui est des ateliers ainsi
qu'un parmi tant d'autres le feraient
ressources qu'ils ont travaillé à
versailles
j'étais interdit de 1200 personnes de
s'inscrire ce qui peut relier derrière
lemaitre d'atelier mais quand on vous
dit que vous êtes et tout le monde le
dit un des plus grands sinon le plus
grand sculpteur sur bois actuelle
comment vous ressentez 7
ça fait toujours plaisir quand on vous
dit quelque chose de ce genre
mais honnêtement je me sens un
déséquilibre personnellement je me sens
un accueil en déséquilibre parce que
bien sûr si vous voulez j'essaie
d'interpréter au maximum tous les
époques
tout au moins celle qui me sont plus
favorables à mon tempérament
mais je ne fais rien des personnels
[Musique]
vous avez des enfants ce qu'est ce
qu'ils font vos enfants ils font lâcher
têtu pourquoi est ce qu'il se passe
culte à savoir j'ai dit non c'est pas
possible face à mme été comme ça c'est
totalement disparaître totalement
disparaître
palmer pas le sculpteur ce métier là le
métier d'artisan d'art
c'est à dire reproduction et herat
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
toute ma famille a toujours été dans la
marbrerie moi j'ai continué la tradition
tout simplement
mais dites moi tout ce qu'on voit c'est
le travail qui attend il y en a partout
évidemment quand on est plus long vol
dans un atelier vous avez parce que on
ne peut pas être embauchés parce que
l'eau il faut un personnel très qualifié
dans ces conditions notre flux il ya une
école de marbrerie mais quand ils
sortent de l'école ils sont des
grossistes en plus et il faut du goût et
du doigt tue parce que ce pôle tout
savoir il faut faire si je dois faire ça
vous arrive à le faire il beaucoup pour
les antiquaires mais des statuts avec un
début des statuts un peu tout et est ce
que vous avez des enfants donc lycée
cheikh de bureau le monde clichy
celui-là fait central et 1 ce qui lui
fait trop la souffrance et les voir
revenir ici j'aime mieux alors métier
c'est à dire que j'ai un compagnon vie
est très bon et dans ces conditions et
j'espère qu'il pourra continuer voilà
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
c'est un endroit est un bâtiment assez
curieux destiné au départ la
présentation d'expositions des meubles
du faubourg-saint-antoine avait
certainement quelques espaces réservés
aux artistes
ici on voit arriver des artistes des
photographes des décorateurs qui comme
vous reprennent les ateliers des
artisans alors le choix de ce quartier
très simple des artistes les professions
libérales cherche des espaces assez
important des locaux de grande dimension
et le quartier du faubourg saint-antoine
est le seul que je sache à paris bien
situé qui possède des locaux importants
de par la disparition est lasse des
artisans du meuble disons nous sommes
reçues quand même nous sommes acceptés
comme une sorte de relève relève de ces
artisans qui disparaissent hélas et
d'une certaine manière nous continuons
cette tradition
faire des choses de proposer des choses
veut à travers cette activité libérale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dites moi monsieur valentin vous êtes
ici depuis longtemps dans cet atelier
dans celui ci
oui oui aux six mois et avant vous étiez
vous acheter d'autres côté-là l'immeuble
de vaucanson à l'hôtel qui est en face
au talent l'autre côté de la rue vous
avez travaillé longtemps là-bas où je
travaillais 40 ans de 36 à 76 et ça
marchait bien
vous avez la note médias des hauts et de
bas vous savez en coûtera 20 clou ça va
pas il faudra tout levier il faut pour
avoir une atelier il faut de l'argent
l'hommage avait établi équipe au micro
les quelques infos qui votre départ d'en
face mais qui va provoquer mon départ
c'est qu'ils ont ils vont construire un
immeuble à l'ail blanc a évacués elle
nous devrons des mises est d'ailleurs
bien et ensuite et pas vu la maquette
dans le coin de la rue ils vont faire un
immeuble devant et puis on va rénover le
vieux du vieil hôtel avons par croirait
qu'ils vont faire les dents des
appartements grand standing remettre à
neuf tout ça
dans cet hôtel dureront une gamme de
différents appartements qui rompt du 2
pièces aussi pièces dans la résidence
qui se trouve devant nous allons
également un choix assez vaste keira du
studio jusqu au 5 pièces tous à 10
modèles de montagne et un des
chefs-d'oeuvre de l'architecturé du
xviie puisqu'il a été construit 1 561
est ce que ça ne tombe pas me cacher aux
yeux des passants avec l'immeuble que
vous allez construire des gens je crois
justement que les affaires culturelles
les monuments historiques y ont pensé
et nous on demandé justement de dégager
toute la partie du rez de chaussée à une
hauteur de trois mètres pour que tous
les piétons qui passent devant justement
puisse apercevoir cet hôtel d'ailleurs
il ya une grande ouverture également sur
le côté passage dallery qui permet
également de voir cet hôtel et qui
pourra appliquer les engagements que
vous construisez et bien
nous avons les amoureux du quartier du
11e et qui veulent rester et demeurer
dans le 11e
et bien entendu nous vendront également
à des gens qui sont amoureux des
vieilles pierres et qui viendront de
partout pour en faire l'acquisition
je pense que c'est le passé historique
justement qu'ils recherchent les
vieilles pierres
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'avais mon atelier à 4-5 minutes de mon
domicile
d'abord ils espéraient promène somptueux
gens viennent voir mon bâtiment mes
fenêtres où j'avais travaillé où il y en
a encore mais keita floor horse est bien
quand j'ai vu qu'on commençait le
démolir
il ya quelque chose qui titillait qui
s'est cassé en ont marre at il eu tort
on est trente ans de ma vie était là
j'allais même le dimanche j'allais à
l'atelier mais qu'ils n'avaient pas
travaillé c'était par plaisir bon je
m'asseyais je lisais j'écrivais quelque
chose voyez vous il n'y avait pas que le
travail il ya bientôt de poésie dont il
y avait un lien avec la musique
et alors là comme s'était tout en bois y
avait alors une sonorité parfaite
c'était c'était un endroit agréable pour
vous promets que nous sommes maîtres de
la mer nous croyons des crèches milieu
et fort le nez dans la poussière
qu'est ce qu'une forme dépouille
et les voir
qui nous a confié
pour le trouble sur lui
écrit offrir cool
tout le monde donc howling vivlamore
vivre la fin par le gris vivre la vie
nous sommes tous ça
et les trois jours
qui nous broie
tout le tour
aytré au four
[Musique]
c'est toute la terre est ronde en deux
saisons les voiles points on va faire ce
qu'ils m'ont donné vie tout fout le camp
[Musique]
les corbeaux qui nous broie peux tu me
dire tout ce qu'on veut des fous
l'écurie à mulhouse
la vie pourrait être super
si l'on voulait dire d'abord pourquoi ce
projet a fait mauvaise traduction
[Musique]